emma bref pour ma carte blanche j'avais
envie de penser à nos enfants et qui
sont les enfants de la république aux
côtés du président de la république dès
2017 nous nous sommes engagés à mettre
plus d'enseignants dans les quartiers
prioritaires c'était une très bonne
mesure c'est une mesure qui à perte et
ses fruits qui a permis des résultats et
nous avons eu des études elles sont
favorables sur les matières principales
nous avons également permis à 2021 718
mille contrats d'apprentissage et donc
de redonner confiance à beaucoup
d'enfants confiance en eux mêmes mais
aussi confiance dans notre système
scolaire maintenant je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin les enseignants que je
rencontre tous les jours me le disent
des académies souffre actuellement à la
rentrée prochaine l'académie de
versailles il manque plus de 1000
enseignants et là c'est un petit peu ma
carte bleue ou blanche mais c'est aussi
un peu mon cri d'alarmé et j'ai
confiance j'ai confiance il faut
revaloriser le métier d'enseignant il
faut pour ça un ministre nous l'avons et
j'ai confiance il faudra le travail mais
c'est un un chantier pour nous à
l'avenir auquel je crois mais qui est
essentiel pour les enfants est
essentielle pour nomades cilic est
essentielle pour l'égalité des chances m